this is the moment opposition party
supporter say armed security Personnel
fired tear gas into their headquarters
in Sierra Leone's Capital Freetown
officials from the country's main
opposition party the old people's
Congress say several people were injured
the police defended their action as long
as they see you spotting green whether
you are sitting on a motorbike or you
are riding a Kaka they will take you out
under embarrass you they'll harass you
that was when I called the leadership
since they could not respond I called
the nearest patrol to that particular
education
as a vote count continues the APC has
questioned its fairness and demanded
better access for its observers its
presidential candidate says election
officials are planning to disenfranchise
their supporters and deny the party
victory
APC
is on an irreversible path to an
overwhelming victory
be rest assured that I
Samurai matu Wilson Kamara
and APC party
would not and shall not accept any
skilled manipulated and unverified
results
he accused the Electoral Commission of
refusing to use video projectors as it
tells the results
election officials say no accredited
person was denied access yeah they have
requested also projects but it's not
possible it's not practicable because
you have about four sets of Italian
staff who are entering the figures and
you have another set of four who are
verified these figures so if you say we
want us to to project this figure which
one do we choose initial results show
the two leading political parties are
doing well in their strongholds
meanwhile there is heavy police and
military presence on the street
the exchanges between the opposition and
electoral officials are making many
people here in Sierra Leone nervous and
owners of shops and other businesses are
watching for any sign of trouble
the Electoral commission says they hope
to release the results early in an
effort to ease tensions but they say
they can't commit to a deadline
while there is come for now on the
streets of many towns and cities
observers are concerned about unfolding
events in other parts of the country
people are worried that if the situation
deteriorates further it could roll back
more than two decades of democracy Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera freedom